[Applaudissements]
la jeune femme y provost remporte la
coupe de france du meilleur fleuriste à
tour et le jour de la st fleur avec sept
autres candidats la concouru avec une
pièce montée pour cinquante convives en
fleurs sur su j'aurais tendance à dire
peut-être le côté très aérien très
ouverts ici c'est ce qui m'a fait le
vraiment le plus peur la stabilité tout
ce qui est un peu technique comme ça
j'ai toujours peur je suis moins sûr de
moi j'ai pourtant oui je suis assez
contente
enfin je suis arrivé au bout de ce que
je voulais faire donc voilà et on peut
toujours faire mieux mais ça aboutit
aujourd'hui c'était la dernière épreuve
de la quarante neuvième coupe de france
du meilleur fleuriste fanni a séduit le
jury par un parcours sans faute
c'est vrai que c'est une régularité dans
le travail donc on a pu constater que
fanni avait plusieurs premiers prix donc
forcément ça fait monter une moyenne
après il faut toujours un gagnant ils
sont douze méritants mais c'est vrai que
fanni s'est décrochée sur plusieurs
épreuves du lot et et a vraiment très
bien travaillé a excellé sur certaines
donc le résultat est tout à fait logique
ça représente tellement de choses enfin
c'est l'aboutissement mon travail depuis
huit ans et est vraiment j'ai travaillé
enfin j'ai travaillé dur et
et voilà celui ci j'ai essayé j'ai bougé
pour y arriver
emportant sio le savoir faire de
l'artisanat
fanny a réalisé son rêve et celui de
toute une profession